croatia will be  the largest recipient of the recovery  and resilience facility compared  to the country's gdp behind that  is indeed also the fact that  croatia has gone through very tough  times if i think  of the earthquake than the pandemic  and here the croatian plan is  outstanding  i really want to thank you for the  excellent cooperation we've been working  very hard but the result is excellent  this recovery and resilience plan  will shape the economy and the society  for  years ahead it will make the european  green deal a reality  it will digitize the country like never  before  and therefore it is as the name says an  investment  in the future of the next generation  so 6.23 billion euros  as you've said andre are to be  dispersed over the next years with very  ambitious projects  the plan approved by the european  commission for croatia so  thank you many thanks for the work and  congratulations to that